so i'd go i'd go back to south carolina
to see the judge
i'm in nebraska that's on the other side
of the [ __ ] country
you know how long it takes to ship a
federal inmate from nebraska
[Music]
not good to [ __ ] to south carolina
they don't put you on american airlines
and fly you a direct flight i'll tell
you that much right [ __ ] now
they don't do that they don't do con
this little they do con air but they hop
skip and jump you
to uh 10 different [ __ ] little
[ __ ] county jails or wherever
you know who has the contract to hold
federal inmates at that time
you know so that i'm bouncing around
yeah so i go from
dude i'm trying to remember now i went
from nebraska
to the small town i was in i sat there
for like a week and then i went to omaha
nebraska which is the big city
it's the town it's the big town in in
nebraska which is they handle all like
the big cases
i sat in omaha for a month maybe two
weeks
i think two weeks until they transfer me
from omaha
i went to what's the federal uh prison
in oklahoma city no right next to
nebraska it's in
um indiana oh uh um
leavenworth leavenworth leavenworth yeah
so they transferred me from
oklahoma to levenworth so sad that i
know this took like yeah
yeah that's an uh a federal prison
encyclopedia
yeah i whenever you need information um
so yeah i so then i go to i go to
leavenworth i'm in leavenworth for
a couple of weeks maybe a month from
leavenworth they put me on
conair and they fly me out to oklahoma
and i sit in oklahoma
in the in the federal prison out there
for like a month
and okay mind you when they're
transferring you around you don't get in
the general population
you're in holding you're in holding for
a month that means no commentary
that means the little tiny toothbrush
with the little tiny toothpaste that
doesn't [ __ ] work
you know what i mean so your butt your
breath's always hot you know what i mean
you get the little tiny deodorant
because i can't buy deodorant so you get
the little tiny deodorant that's
one one thing and it comes out and it
[ __ ] pops and hits the floor and
you know what i mean the one razor that
just basically just cuts you and cuts
you and comes
yeah i didn't even get razors yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got like
you can request they'll give it to you
you shave they give it you give it back
they watch you use it
yeah well you take the razor out and use
a knife
you know what i mean yeah you can pop
out the razor blade now you got a razor
[ __ ] put it on the end got it i mean
it's just it's [ __ ]
so you guys are ingenious but if you're
just trying to [ __ ] survive
like i'm not involved in all that [ __ ]
my life's miserable because you guys
want to kill each other yeah
so they transferred you back to south to
where south carolina or what eventually
i get back to south carolina after
leavenworth
i go to oklahoma and then oklahoma i go
to uh atlanta then atlanta i go to
lovejoy then from lovejoy i get [ __ ]
transferred to some other little
listen and mind you through this whole
process i almost starved to death twice
okay they left me in a [ __ ] room to
to sit me somewhere for a second while
they went and did something and forgot
about me
for like 18 [ __ ] hours no [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude i was there wasn't
there was nowhere to get water in the
[ __ ] room i was gonna die i was gonna
[ __ ] die in that room if somebody
would just open the door to see if
somebody was in there
yeah yeah so then i me and then i get
put into some little [ __ ] [ __ ] um
jail in south carolina where they starve
you
where i almost [ __ ] starve to death
you know so now i've got ptsd
from that [ __ ] so yeah no i finally get
back out to south carolina i don't get
back out to south carolina to see my
judge until
after january after traveling from
november
getting picked up in like the beginning
of november so i don't even get to see
my judge until the middle of january
and how much time had passed in that
that time period like
three months three months 90 days it
took about 90 days to get me just to get
me in front of the judge
god bro yeah yep and then you got
six months yeah and then they killed my
paper
what does that mean uh they released me
without federal probation
and how does that happen my probation or
my my judge said that i'm not a
supervisable
yeah some guy's a light like i'm a
flight risk because they've had listen
they've had to extradite me from from
from from from nebraska to south
carolina they've had to extradite me
from
florida to south carolina multiple times
and they're like
it's just costing us too much money to
ship you all over the country because
you can't stay in one spot
and he keeps running and i keep taking
off i keep absconding on probation
but hey i'm not a career criminal i i'm
not a drug addict
you know what i mean i'm not somebody
who
is in the higher category for recidivism
yeah he's not going to
go into a bank with a [ __ ] ak-47 it's
not like that it's gonna come back i'm
not a danger to the public
yeah i'm not gonna you know i'm not i'm
not a raper or a stabber or nothing like
that right right right
yeah i'm sorry i was gonna say the a lot
of guys
i've known guys that have literally like
they'll get five or ten years
they'll have five years paper they'll
get paper meaning
probation they'll get out and violate
and come back to prison and then so
they'll violate their paper
and go in front of the judge and be like
the ju and the judge will
they used to do this all the time they
don't do it as much anymore the judge
would say okay look you've got
you have three years left on your
probation you know
if i give you a cup if i release you and
you put you back on on probation
you know you're gonna be okay and they
will you know you're gonna
do the right thing there there are guys
that'll be like absolutely not
i'm gonna violate again like they'll get
caught smoking pot or doing drugs
they'll go i'm going to do drugs again
your honor and they'll look at them and
go well then you're going to go back to
prison well then i'll go back to prison
but i'm going to keep doing it and the
judge will just look at them and go
would you rather i quash your paper and
they'll say yeah
okay well then you got to go to jail for
a year it's usually one-third
so they'll go you go to jail for a year
and when you get out you don't have any
probation okay i'll go back for a year
weird so they'll go back for a year oh
listen i got five years paper
yeah but the problem is i owe six
million that's rough
he's got somebody up his [ __ ] yeah
for five [ __ ] years
she's a nice lady though she i mean she
is nice she's just strict
most of them are nice yeah yeah they
have to do their job right i think the
craziest thing about all this
is like he had a victimless crime you
basically scammed
scammers you scammed the financial
institution the banks well there were
some victims in there
yeah there's a couple victims there's
people some people offer you you had
legitimate victims like people
individuals you were taking
straight from their bank accounts right
no these these are credit cards they
don't lose any money at all they do have
to make some phone calls and it's a pain
in the ass
but look if i take your credit card
information and i run up five thousand
dollars on your credit card
and then you get the bill in the next
month and you go holy [ __ ]
right you just call them and they they
they chalk it up to fraud
right they go they yeah you file a
police report
you didn't steal anybody really i was
just i was just manufacturing financial
transaction devices
right yeah that was his that was the
actual charge was uh
charges access to what was it called uh
uh a fraudulent transaction device yeah
manufacturing of a truck fraudulent
that's just amazing which they dropped
the more time that you got
then wild ain't it well i mean it's
amazing
well it is but i was also look i was
high profile
there was a lot of coverage there was
they're not going to let me skate
the truth is my look the truth is that
people involved in my case
most likely were like if it hadn't been
high profile that it they would have
been like nah they would have shrugged
it off i would have gotten five or ten
years no big deal
but boom a lot of [ __ ] press hammer
this guy
him they dropped he's supposed to get 10
years they dropped the charge because
the ups guy
never should have opened the package but
they wouldn't drop the aggravated
identity theft
because they could prove that so he got
he got two years
yeah yeah i got the mandatory and the
mandatory minimum for that which i got
because the guy should not have opened
he never should have opened the package
he didn't have authorization those were
sealed
sealed packages those that's did he get
in trouble no no
but i mean he helped me out yeah he
helped me and hurt me i guess
yeah but i mean look
he can't they can't put him on the stand
he's got to either get on the stand
and implicate himself i opened a i
opened
a a postal i opened a piece of mail i
broke
a federal law so most people are
probably going to get on the stand and
say i can't answer that or
he's going to get on the stand and say
look when i called the the
u.s post office i felt they were
instructing me to open the package
and that's why i open it that gives them
an out you see what i'm saying
so either and then guess what now that's
no good
what was in the package is no good as
evidence anyway because he's saying you
told him to do it yeah
so we can't you either way we can't use
it so
his probation i'm sorry his um
public defender got the u.s attorney to
drop that part
and say and then he said okay i'll drop
that but he's got to do the two years
and they said and he you know came back
to him and he was like [ __ ] two years as
a gift compared to 10. so dig this
though
this is something i didn't i didn't
forgot to tell you guys
so when i get back in front of the judge
and um
she's reading she's reading uh off all
my charges and i get my get my paperwork
back
um with all my violations on it like
because it's like it was like
uh there's different levels of violation
and in the federal system like
everything's structured like okay if you
fall in this category of like a level
one violation they can only give you x
amount of months
for and then they have to kick you back
out again or if it's a level two then
they can give you x amount of months or
if you know what i mean so
i'm going over my paperwork and
i'm reading my my my report that my
probation officer had left
and she said that uh she went to my
apartment
i had she called me on several occasions
and i didn't answer her calls
so she went to my apartment and i didn't
answer the door and that
the um landlord had just happened to be
there like cleaning it out and she said
that i had moved
so she violated me from absconding for
probation yeah
not had nothing those two dudes that
busted me never went and [ __ ]
told them pulled home probation officer
nothing really
never told never so i ran i ran for no
[ __ ] reason i could have stayed
i could have stayed in miami and and
just tried to do the probation thing
but i didn't know and i and you know
i didn't know they weren't going to say
anything that was [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
knew they weren't going to stay
she didn't know she had no idea that any
of that had even happened
and they violated me because i i just
absconded
yeah that's [ __ ] [ __ ] wild
foreign